and our shoutout tonight for a rookie
journalist who showed right away on his
very first assignment he's a real pro
diving into the use of solitary
confinement for prisoners a practice
that many leading criminologists say
amongst her torture when used over long
periods of time the untold story of what
was happening in the Tennessee prison
system to women as young as 16 was the
first story ever published by a graduate
student named Ellen Arthur's by far the
biggest thing I had ever written and the
first thing I had really published what
Arthur discovered with the team from The
Tennessean newspaper and USA Today was
dozens of women locked up in solitary
confinement for months and months simply
because they had medical conditions or
behavioral issues local jails could not
accommodate my first thought was sort of
disbelief but then the more I learned
about it the more I started to feel if
not injustice definitely a sense of a
sadness that a lot of people were stuck
in this position Arthur who was active
in trying to help people who have been
in prison with a streaming video art
show connected with a whistleblower to
help him dr. Allie winters a senior
clinical therapist who helped him and
his readers understand the toll of
lengthy solitary confinement everybody
changes everybody their you you cannot
go into solid a human being cannot go
into solitary confinement and not change
I don't think I was the first person she
tried to reach out to it might have been
the least likely at grad school
journalism student in New York City but
for whatever reason nobody else ran with
it and I did and fortunately were able
to make some impact Arthur's printed
stories and a companion video produced
by The Tennessean and the nonprofit
Marshall project told a compelling story
featuring the plight of some of the
women who had been through it
you're in prison you know
I made it a crime I said I've not been
found guilty of that crime yet
it's never easy to hear people in these
cases I'm I'm pretty much asking people
to recount the worst moment of their
life and sometimes the worst years of
their life and it's it certainly takes a
mental toll on them and it takes a
mental toll on me any journalist who's
reported on this kind of thing can vouch
for that and you know it's I cared about
these people you know not you know some
of them had done bad things in their
lives for sure but I felt for them
believed they deserve their day in court
but as a rookie investigative journalist
Arthur says he was worried he wasn't up
to the task I thought maybe I'm just not
good enough to do this and that it would
be a real disservice to these people to
put this amateur basically on this this
thing which is essentially their lives
that I had to get it right because if I
didn't you know they're recounting these
very painful things that they've never
had a chance to talk about and if I
botched that I would never forgive
myself his stories became big news in
Tennessee helping lead to the release of
some of the teenagers who had been
locked up in solitary confinement a 16
year old is out of prison tonight after
a nonprofit paid her $60,000 bail Fox 13
Zack Crenshaw was there as Rosalind
Holmes reunited with some of her family
members in her slippers and khakis 16
year old Rosalind bird was on the
outside for the first time in more than
three months my boy and the stories led
to a new law signed by the governor that
essentially curbed the practice for
minors in ordered better oversight with
involving adults the legislation that
was introduced as a result was was
introduced by a Democrat and a
Republican so it was it was you know
pretty bipartisan and the governor said
you know I'm sign-in it the idea that
maybe one person or two people could get
out of
of solitary confinement because of this
I think was a responsibility to them a
responsibility to dr. winters for what
she had witnessed which takes its own
toll I think that was in the forefront
of my mind it was just you can't let
these people down they stuck it out
through this the least you can do is
finish this story and you did it did I
finished it in the hospital room the
night my son was born while my wife and
baby were asleep a life-changing moment
for everyone involved congratulations
Alan Arthur on your son and your story
well that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here next week good night